so this is work with a lot of awesome
people inside and outside of Google
listed here and I'll give a talk about
on this mysterious title really not last
couple of years has been an amazing ride
for field of HR it ability there are a
lot of papers published work shelves or
symposiums but I still see this as a
drop in the ocean because the introvert
ability is such a complex problem we
have all the problems that traditional
machine learning folks have computations
robustness and whatnot but in addition
to that we have this another complex
thing that we have to worry about called
humans in fact they're so complex that
there's a whole field for it it's called
psychology or cognitive science in
perhaps this complexity is what keeps
people interesting interested in the
field but this is also why we need to
decide where we're going in this field
because we have to row in the same
direction to get somewhere you're all
wrong in different directions
we might just spin around in circle and
not going anywhere it's important to
mention that interpretability is not a
new problem back in eighties expert
systems we already had thought about
this problem of how do we communicate
something complex to humans and I think
it's reasonable to say we haven't quite
solved that problem yet
so today we're going to talk about first
where are we going and second where are
we now what kind of method do we have
does it work does it not work if so when
and I'll suggest an idea how we can do
better then we'll come back to that idea
and see okay now I have this idea how do
we how can we do even better and finally
we'll end with some remarks on what sort
of things we should watch out in our
journey first where we're going unlike
traditional machine learning problems so
supervised problems where the community
generally agrees that yeah accuracy
while not perfect is generally the good
direction to head down to we don't have
such a thing and interpretability
because it's complex we have to ask a
little harder question hard to have
mathematical definition of
interoperability and that's what bin woo
was talking about we need to define
interpretability on the context on their
condition on the user who are you
serving for so we have to ask this
harder question that involves value
judgment what are you trying to do and
ultimately what are you trying to
achieve what do you care
so your goal is your goal but I would
like to share my goal love to hear what
your goals are but my goal is to give
people tool so that they can help
themselves to use machine learning more
responsibly I really believe that a lot
of people want to do the right thing but
sometimes maybe they don't have a tool
for adjusting on the analyzing just new
term they added in the loss function
what does it do what kind of feedback
loop does it create
they just don't have the right tool so
the goal is to give them that tool so
that they can use machinery
and there's this detour not complete
list but one the tool should help you to
make sure that your values are aligned
such as fairness and the tools should
help you to confirm whether your domain
extra knowledge is reflected when you
want it
and I particularly care that this works
for everyone because when medical domain
like high-risk domains we have domain
expertise like doctors holds critical
knowledge about how to make the right
decision
but they don't they may not have
computer science background it's rare to
see someone who has PhD in computer
science an MD they do exist
there's completely right but it's rare
but those are the times when
interpretability becomes also you know
society point of view this powerful tool
called machine learning anybody should
be able to leverage it regardless of
where they went to school or whether
they went to college or not
it's also important to think about what
are not our goals it is not about making
everything interpretable there are
plenty of applications where you just
don't care about interpretability you
don't need it then you know don't worry
about it
it's also not about understanding every
single thing about the model I think
about interpret E as a translation
problem you have oh I speak two
languages I speak Korean in English and
there's some words in Korean that I
cannot quite translate in English but I
can't kind of describe get around it and
kind of get the meaning across it's not
exact but it's useful that's how I view
interpretability method you're trying to
map these two things it's not exact
motion machine language as human
language
but as long as it's useful tool for you
to achieve the goal it's meaningful it's
also bad about against hot developing
highly complex models it just means that
we have more work to do it's also not
about in my view gaining user trust or
purely for fairness in fact I think an
interpretability method that is really
useful is to convince you to not trust a
model when that's the case in fact
there's this paper that is mind-blowing
I highly recommend you to take a look
this is a nature published article a
couple months ago about how they train
the hip fracture medical image and
thought that it was reading something
meaningful from the medical image about
how whether this patient is something
about this patient whether it is
efficient cheery or not but it turns out
that it wasn't it was actually paying
attention to the machine that the image
was taken the model of the machine and
all these other confounding factors not
the image
and in this case what interpretability
message should do is say well I don't
know what this model is doing it's doing
this weird thing and that's when it's
it's not about trust it's about helping
you to decide whether this model should
be used in your real application safely
or not
so I gave you a direction that at least
I'm I would like to head to and let's
now talk about where are we now what
kind of method do we have there are lots
of different kinds of interpretability
method but just like we do I'm gonna
talk about post-training
interpretability methods what does that
mean it just means you have a model you
cannot change the model and your goal is
to do best as best as you can to
interpret this model so to be concrete
let's say you have a model like your
network takes an image and it predicts
that's a jungle bird and you want to
answer given this model give me the
evidence of prediction in other words
why was this a joke okay so the most
popular method that we saw a couple
times in the past tops is daylian see
maps what does it do well it simply
takes a lot of methods are based on this
first-order gradient so take probability
of say Jukka bird and test take a
first-order gradient with respect to
every single pixel so that means in
suitably if I change this pixel a little
bit how much would the probability of
jungle bird change if it changes a lot
it's important pixel if it doesn't it's
not an important picks up that's cool so
again the promise of this method called
saliency mask is that these pixels are
the evidence of prediction
so then we can ask this little really
simple sanity check question which is if
it's of evidence of prediction that when
the prediction changes then the
explanation should change and you can
think about an extreme case when the
prediction is random explanation should
really change so we test that this is
work with awesome PhD student and that
used to be a Google Julius so now now
what we did is the following we took a
beautifully train Network take the
picture predictor to jungle bird and
gives us this sail you see map now the
sailorman
looking at it kind of makes sense the
belly of the bird is kind of important
the chick of the bird is important okay
then we copied this Network and we start
randomizing the weight the learned
weights from the top layer in a
cumulative fashion all the way to the
bottom layer so what I did here is I
just messed up the perfectly
good-looking Network now completely the
the prediction is completely random with
the garbage right so you would think
that explanation should change it
doesn't
now you may argue well but these two
pictures technically different the sky
it looks a little darker here for
remember the final consumer over your
method is human and as a human I don't
know if I will draw a completely
different conclusion based on these two
pictures belly still important
she still important and we do this for a
lot of different methods including my
own own work starting from the logit
layer just larger and in cascading
fashion all the way down to the most
bottom layer so here you're looking at
completely randomized Network and as you
can see some method barely change here's
some more reason picture that you VSS
put out some of the more recent work
predating clingstone white life and
remember this second column has random
prediction it's pretty similar for first
column
so we're shocked by this and we're like
okay well what about different kind of
randomization what if we train a network
with random labels so we did that this
is a network trained with the correct
label and this this we trained with
random labels some method you can still
see so digit zero but it never weren't
what zero is and the vanilla gradient
seems to be doing the best and and and a
lot of methods that we are we listed out
here or based on doing some fancy things
on top of analog radio so what is this
what are we what can we gain from this
result well I think this is showing you
something that I repeatedly see in my
work oh yes do you look at data sets
which aren't really foreground
background okay so even see far is a
little bit less foreground background
there is something in mist there's
definitely a central object which is
being protected in like the sea in the
case of a fuzzy green background yes so
in my admire the work that benchmark
data said that I'm about to talk about
might might get you to that answers that
were just bias to look at the center
object right yeah let me yeah let's give
me answer that question when I get there
so what is this well come from oh yeah
yes so so I'm in prison say a
three-letter code right that's act which
was which was semantics so you could
look for small curves and then these
curves the next level big formal ooh
and then finally a label it has a zero
there amazing the last layer only tells
me that I don't know it's a zero but you
are still detecting the features so that
is not lost when you are randomizing the
last layers of the network this came to
him from point let me answer the
question so first of all this one this
is zero it never uh well actually let me
answer it this way the promise of the
salience email is evidence of prediction
right
I didn't it's not the promises I'll give
you ten things and what I think one of
them might be the abbot what caused the
prediction not that it's saying what I
gave you is why this picture is a bird
right and I think what you're getting at
is yes you might extract some features
and maybe salience in math is showing
that feature that might have been used
for prediction but that wasn't the
promise of the methods in other words
think of it this way like you have a
medical image right and your cancer cell
got into the doctor and doctors are
looking at this alien see math right do
you think if the doctor if the salience
map is not promising either getting you
those high Rico or high precision it's
just getting you something right
something some feature that my predicted
might be caused cause the prediction
that's not really what the evidence of
prediction is right it should give you
the smallest and sufficient set of that
cause of the prediction
you only look at the first order like
the effect of the single fixes and knots
effector sets of tips yes yeah
significant could be a combination yes
totally agree so I will actually talk
about it's a really great segue to my
next work which does basically that cool
all right
so let's talk about this confirmation
bias because I think it's one of the
most important thing when we work on
interpretability method when we see
these pictures we like it we expect it
to see a bird so we saw a bird and we
liked it and for all these years
we're like yeah we see you Bart if this
makes sense this is a bias it's very
well studied in a lot of other fields
and that's what I think we are seeing
here we really should have been passing
this test long time ago and
coincidentally a couple of other papers
discover similar symptoms one beautiful
paper mathematically proved that some of
these features some of these methods are
actually just reconstructing the input
it has nothing to do with prediction but
some papers when they're out of their
way to test this with human experts and
they show that yeah they do help human
experts so why we don't know that yet
something in here is helping human
experts but we need to do more study to
figure out what that is so that we can
amplify that recent work at elegant work
by Sanjeev Arora from Princeton that's
just a simple fix elegant fix to pass
this test with it is to be seen to check
whether this method also formulate a
faithful explanation that's TBD
but I think it's a good great start
so okay this test kind of dumb test I
think it's a such a low bar test we
should be really pessimist so then next
step we thought about can we put methods
in the harder test so this is work with
sherry young at Google brain the goal is
to make a benchmark data set so that any
interpretability method can evaluate
that because in this case we have ground
truth we know exactly where in the image
should be important so how do we do that
oh it's pretty simple we get scene data
set forest kitchen Stadium and then we
get an object from MS Coco because it's
nicely chopped out dog chopped out the
backpack and so on it's okay then what
we do is we paste this thing in every
single image for all classes uniform so
if I were to classify scenes the dog
should give you no information so we
know that dog the attribution methods or
salient see map should not highlight the
dog says we can go one step farther and
we can do relative testing too we can
put this dog in some of the classes like
forest and not the others and that means
dog will give signal to what the forest
scene is so we do that too
and in particular I think it's important
to notice what we are focusing on here
what we're trying to measure
we believe that interpretability method
makes pretty much similar types of ways
mistakes as machine learning models and
here in this work we are focusing on
false positives interpretability method
said i'm important but model doesn't
think so
so under then we suggest three metrics
I'm gonna talk a little more about the
first one but quickly the input
dependence like rate and independent
rate dependence rate is input dependent
is that if I change the input the image
in a way that it matter then they should
really change input independence radius
kind of adversarial patch where we
initialize a pixel with a dog and we
gradient descent such that that patch of
pixel shouldn't matter to neural network
and we see the Adhan tribution method
still went crazy on the dog but so the
details are on the paper but let me talk
a little bit more about model contrast
score what this does is we make this
data set remember we paste the dog so we
know exactly where the dog is we shrink
two models one to classify the scenes
and the other one to classify the
objects so the ID when you show you to
talk about in our data set there's at
all there's stack pack and ten different
classes and what that does is we expect
where the object is should have a high
contrast in these two models right
there's one it's just looking to see the
other one we know the OB job is
important because scene is uniformly
distributed scene doesn't give you any
information about what the talks what
the object should be so we did that and
we got scores these are popular methods
grad cam does pretty well smooth but
also those okay T cap which is the
method I'm about to talk about those
also okay we are open sourcing soon data
set and models and everything on this
beam dataset
let's begin license issues sorry now so
that's harder yes so what are these
matters it are interpretive matters yeah
the great game vanilla gradient smoother
and Integra gradian seriously methods oh
they're all silly - yes so they all some
some subset of the pixels yes the except
T cap which is a global method what's
the exact time average average
attribution so I have a lot of dog and
dog pictures and scene pictures I so
forests and forest plus dog and I have a
lot of them and I measure how much
contrast is in each feature and I
average them over and that's this number
interpreter what that's poor 2.10 how
good we are
I see yes so that's a more complicated
question higher the better for now the
mechs this one is it only respect to the
same classifier because maybe detecting
here issues of the classifier and not
some general issues good point so this
is only thinking about these two models
that we trained it's not perfect it's
not gonna be general overall however I
think it's at least better than doing
nothing it's limited also to
semi-natural data set so it's not
completely natural but I think it's it's
a great start once we pass this to us
and we're nailing it then we go to the
next level yes there's another quick
question are ready to a size question so
what do you fight just do a segmentation
I label one segment together that sounds
like I will pass this test segment the
dog okay and then but they once you're
second man you have to attribute
correctly right so yes I yes I have yeah
I mean if you have a perfect
segmentation methods as far as I know
superficial method doesn't like exactly
carve out the dog I find it difficult to
maybe maybe you can do it if you can do
that and you can appropriately put the
right number then I think you're good
however I don't think you will be able
to pass or like do all well in this
three metrics maybe you can yes it
sounds like this Alberto especially that
if I have a perfect segmentation
algorithm I can pass all the
interpretive results I start with a non
interpret post segmentation algorithm
segmentation model that works perfectly
and then I can pass all the
interpretivism
that's not I think a lot of
interpretability method actually uses
segmentation like Lyman sharp actually
super pixel segments and then attribute
I haven't seen a really good
segmentation method that just carve-outs
a dog perfectly and attributed if you
can I think that's a great start
however I don't even if you can I do i I
think these two measures are measuring
slightly different things so for example
I don't think it would have passed the
input independence rate what it is the
following I have a scene and I put a dog
in somewhere and then I gradient descent
only on the dark side to make sure that
that part of the pixel that set of
pixels don't matter to suit the network
just nicked off decision so it's all
personal in a different way right that's
what you say it doesn't matter let's say
you did the perfect segmentation on that
then you would have to put something on
the dog right if you can put the right
number on the dog I think that you're
good but I think it's a little harder
than what you're describing
all right so we talked about this so
where are we now in this method while
it's helpful sometimes may not be
working in the way that we expect so how
can we do better so again the problem
here is post training explanation
I changed the example now you're looking
at a cash motion picture passes through
the neural network says it's a cash
machine the goal is to answer why was
this a cash machine
now let's stare at this salient emag
where we just talked about to help us
think about what do we really want
what's the goal and I stare at this
picture you see this human in front of
the cash machine that's kind of
highlighted and I started wonder maybe
the human mattered human concept
mattered the fact that human was in the
car in the picture helped predicting
cash machine and I also noticed this
weird thing this heart behind the human
the wheel is highlighted for some reason
and I want to know whether that was that
matter because that sounds more
problematic and if there were important
if there were a thing then I want to
know whether these were which one was
more important human that maybe a little
better comforting than if it's a wheel
right and I would also like to know if
it's just this picture or all cash
motion pictures
the problem is that you can't really
Express these concepts as a set of
pixels especially across many images I
think it's getting back to your point
that maybe it's some higher-level thing
and also if you had these concepts in
the input feature then you're fine well
you didn't I just came up with it and
the model is all that you trained so
wouldn't it be great if we have a
quantitative way of measuring how
important these concepts are that's what
we did it's called testing with concept
activation vectors the goal is to you
give me a concept that you care such as
gender or race then if it mattered to
the model then I'll tell you in number
between zero and one how important the
concept was for the prediction so giving
you giving you a slightly different
example running example throughout the
talk it's gonna be our zebra and I'm
interested in whether this stripe nice
cones that matter for predicting zebra
what's the definition of the concept
it's coming in the next day so what is
the context like you talked about this
concept thing it sounds good well what
is it well we define concept as a vector
and doing the simplest possible thing
what do we do well to define concept you
need a couple of examples of concepts
like striped pictures and you need some
random images then you pass these images
into the network that you're interested
in investigating and you know layer I'll
talk about which layer how to pick this
layer in a layer you gather all the
activations of these concept papers and
random pictures
then we do the simplest thing we just
strain a linear classifier find the
vector that's orthogonal to that
classifier and that's your concept
vector what is that well it's just a
vector that points from random direction
to concept direction this is not new
we're two back paper already talked
about gender vector lots of other papers
talked about this existence of this
vector and that's what we call
concentrator yes it doesn't have to be
necessarily but it would have to be it
is not completely something random so
for example that's actually important
here everything on one set is just a
line drive everything on the other side
isn't aligned right so I see you mean
between these two I see oh I thought
you're asking different questions I mean
yes yeah this has to be no line or you
can have some wine there's a reason why
this guy isn't here but as long as the
majority of them are but it's from the
same it's from the same industry yes it
has two random digital images it's
better if it's ignore flee from training
distribution a really important point in
practice because then you can learn just
better a vector you just learn or
tighter boundary yes I love that
question
so we do many many times or now we do a
simple statistical testing based on
there
all right so we have a cap we have this
vector now it represents a concept now
how do we get this quantitative measure
that I talked about or T cap score it's
also really simple to get T cap score we
take the probability of zebra and we're
taking the derivative directional
derivative with respect to that vector
that we just got so what is this well
entreatingly what it does is if I move
my picture to be more like the concept
or a little less like the concept how
much would the probability of the zebra
swing if it rings a lot it's important
concept if it doesn't then it's not an
important concept and then we do this
for many many zebra pictures then we
just take an average this is if you had
a hundred zebra pictures how many of
them having zebra concept was positively
contributing prediction of that cause
this is simplest possible way to define
key cap score you can put an inequality
you can do negative to do all sorts of
things that fits your bill but this is
just simplest thing that I thought of
the first time yes
what else so for example right like if I
take a zebra picture I change it to half
the zebra picture spider by teaming the
pixels that doesn't change any of this
so maybe the gradient you might see had
exactly zero
oh I think you can do fancy other things
to make sure that things are even
tighter we don't do that in this basic
peek at work right so I mean you talked
of several methods for measuring
leniency but you only use yes it's a
great point so you can combine say
integrative gradient or shop value to do
concept with your attribution this is
like kind of I think of this as a campus
like a vanilla method that that I put it
out there it's a simple and people can
do things right so we have this simple
simple T curve score definition and now
I'm gonna get to bins bins questions in
this question we have the same thing how
do you validate this cab we're gonna do
a small cute statistical testing there's
also qualitative way to convey and
confirm this concept vector but I'm
gonna talk about quantitative way so we
talked a lot about other versary example
in hospital or before me today how do we
know we know that high dimensional space
things are a little funky so how do we
know that we're not getting this high
sensitivity by chance so here's one way
to safeguard it not perfect but one way
so just like Peter said we can these set
of pictures are random and therefore we
can have any set of many as many as
random images we want from each site
we're gonna get a cap that are slightly
different perhaps from each cap for a
given target zebra we're gonna get many
many t cap scores and you can view this
as samples from a distribution and if in
fact the stripe nessam portent for zebra
you're gonna see something as Gaussian
nice like this so most of the time in a
lot of calves get the stripe nice calves
the ticket score was high
and then what we do is we compare that
to random cow where random cow is where
this is random and the other one is also
random but similar training training
distribution and we show that the mean
of these two distributions are
statistically significantly different
because it's not it's you're in you're
in trouble it's as good as random then
you might as well not use it so if your
concept do not pass does not pass this
test and we say oh sorry you gave me
this concept but maybe model didn't use
it we can't give you an answer how do we
do the test it's not a perfect test but
a test
okay so I talked about this this this
Tcat work but why should you care well I
think it's useful in a couple of
settings at first when you have the
training stage a lot of times you may
have this like intuition you saw a
mistake and you're like oh maybe that
was the issue and you have hypotheses
and you can basically have hypothesis
testing with the machine learning
already trained the machine learning in
the loop and of course if you input
feature did not include it oops you
don't have to go back and retrain the
model you just use this and try to get
the answer for evolution so some result
so first it's a tiny difference and each
experiment but we do send it to
experiment in this case in other words
if we know the ground truth what were
the important concepts are then would
TCAP match because it doesn't match then
we're in trouble so we did this test we
had three costs images like taxi and
soccer and and cucumber at the leave and
then we I program ethically added this
caption potentially you know easy and
what I did there is essentially creating
two concepts in this image image concept
and caption concept so I will create a
scenario where the model can use one or
the other
how do I do that well I can create four
different datasets where sometimes I'll
you give perfect caption so whenever
there is a cap I write cap sometimes I
give hundred percent new easy caption
whenever there's a cab I write like
tiger or something and it's
just really awesome classes and this is
different data that is just to encourage
train different models that those
different things and how do we know the
ground truth well you can test the model
that's trained on this data set with a
data without a caption so if the model
did use and only relied on caption it's
not going to do well because I didn't
give you caption if we actually looked
at the image it's gonna do pretty well
so there is our ground truth
so as I'm very happy to learn that
teacup score matches with grantors
pretty well so this blue is accuracy and
the Green Line is tikal score four
images and you want to see roughly blue
line with hanging out with a green line
and here this is a different class you
see the accuracies like right here it
looks pretty high but it's actually
random cuz there are three classes 33%
random this is pretty low and it looks
like you got a major score matches so
maybe well maybe but but being like
that's cool but like maybe this case was
so simple and it's a toy example maybe
say again see maps can do it too maybe
so we tested that we have board we have
many different for different methods and
we have testing images without captions
and remember this is all none of these
are ma none of these models look at the
caption captions are not important right
however a lot of saliency maps looks at
the caption oh caption no caption no
caption right so that sounds problematic
but mean maybe you cherry pick this
picture so we did talkers test we hired
50 Turkish and asked given these two
series of pictures were three different
classes do you think the image was
important or the caption was important
the findings are pretty interesting so
remember there are two concepts right so
you pick one or the other random is
50-50 humans to 52% they can't tell they
can't tell whether image was important
or caption was important and they're
always split in half half little
truckers were like oh my god it's
definitely images half of them oh my god
it's definitely captions we do pilot
question this is actually really
important question
tarz quality can vary as you may know so
you have to do this pilot testing before
that to make sure they understand the
task they're not randomly clicking in
they are optimizing for the performance
so we give them like if you get this
answers right we'll give you like five
percent twenty dollars more
something that I find it fascinating
though in this from this Turkish
experiment is that people are so
confident whoever they are wrong or
right or incorrect 40% of pork parker's
that I am as confident as I will ever
and this is not just Turkish I actually
see this symptom over and over again you
see something you like and you think
you're right of course you're right then
you like it and you have like boosting
confidence in that answer this is
exactly the confirmation bias that we
should be careful this is why we need to
be very careful of taking and taki on
our feature humans feature which is
device
so we got excited after this sin hae
experiment and we ran tikal on two
widely used image prediction models and
we ran a bunch of different concept sets
one color race and objects in fire
engine the red concept and green concept
were high green was high because a lot
of fire engines were sitting on the
grassy field and that sounds good to you
right red fire engine unless you're from
Australia Canberra anybody from what's
really Oh are you from camera hours no
okay
I've met actually someone who know who
knew exactly where this picture was
taken from it's like a wonder fire
station so there's a good reason
actually why fire engines should be
yellow because at night
elbows are more visible than red so
fairly is like cycled some psychologists
argue that we should have a yellow fire
engine but so this might be showing you
some geographical bias the countries
where fire engines are ready if you
remember at the very first deep dream
blog post where they discovered this
neuron that shows a muscular arm and
they conjectured that oh maybe when when
predicting dumbbell muscular arm is an
important factor and now you can
quantitatively verify yes arms were
important and in this case I didn't have
arms dat affect all the other data said
I got it from my publicly available race
dataset so I went onto Google search
image search and I searched arms and I
collected 33 images and it passed
statistical testing at least for this
layer and the answer that was consistent
with prior literature
so perhaps reminding going back to our
goal then we started to talk with
perhaps this tool can help you to see
whether your values are online in your
model
now really excited with this results we
went to doctors we went we work with
doctors who study diabetic retinopathy
so I believe retinopathy or gr is
treatable if you discover early but too
late if you discover a little later you
lose your sight so we have a model in
medical brain that can predict the our
level pretty well like 85% and our
question was well but is it doing it in
a way doctors would have done because we
want to eventually deploy this model to
rural areas where there are no doctors
so we went to a doctor who she told us
what kind of concepts that she would
before India level for this is more
severe than Lolita
oh thank you and and then we went also
ask her what are the concept that you
don't look for we do the same thing for
more mild level of dr i of course we
have images that associated with these
concepts so and then we use tikal to ask
the model what do you think for model
erm level 4 where prediction accuracy
was high the model said yes I am doing
something that doctors would have done
ready slow something that dr. stone
before look look into when they look at
this class great is hi good story during
a little different when the model has
mediocre accuracy it turns out that when
model it has mediocre accuracy for this
the a level one it's looking at a
concept that doctors would not look at
so we dig this farther and we realize
that the model often confused with level
1 and level 2 and level 2 has a lot of
HMA and they realize all our labels are
noise because doctors don't really agree
with each other what level it should be
and that might be hinting you that
perhaps using this tool you can figure
out whether your domain extra knowledge
is well reflected
so I talked about decaf this is a way of
giving you whether the concept of your
choice was important or not and how
important they were only in if and only
if the network learned about that
concept so here's some self promoting
sites I've been really thrilled to see
responses from inside and outside of
academia about this work
sundar talked about this work at Google
i/o and I was honored to go to UNESCO
impaired Center in Paris to receive one
of the over and as a citizen
cutting-edge technology and in inside of
academia Kerry Kyle worked on this paper
of helping doctors sorting medical
images with respect to the concepts of
their twist so using their language and
in this paper was a part of the best
paper on a row mentioning high
conference this year a couple of weeks
ago I met this Eric person Eric who
works at aerospace in cooperation who
used tikal to interpret storm prediction
models cat for cap 3 they based on
concepts like eyes of the storm and so
on who's able to interpret this model
that's somewhere helpful helpful another
student in Switzerland she extended
tikal two regression models and worked
with doctors for Brett breast cancer and
was able to
but I see this work as really a way I'd
like a white canvas really like what
you're saying there's a lot more things
that can be done so salience EMAP method
there's a first paper I think 2009 by to
meet Rohan who is now a train he brought
this paper on using the first sort of
gradient with respect to pixel and then
there has been a lot of great work
following that trying to do like even
better things and some other things so I
think of Tikal as like a first branch of
this new direction and therefore there's
a lot of the mutations that I would like
to spell it out to you
so concepts in Tikal has to be
expressible using examples so if you
want to express concept of love I'm not
sure how you can do that also
concepts has to be provided by human
experts or the users you need some
examples while the number of examples
might be are pretty small they're what
we discussed it where we find out
fifteen to thirty three is is giving you
pretty good we go but some domains maybe
that's not enough then you have to go
get your concepts I think there's a lot
of exciting work that can be done for
discovering concepts automatically we
did some work for images but I think
there's a lot more great way to do this
of course decap is not causal in fact a
lot of interpretability methods are not
causal completely correlations so
developing more proper causal way to
discover concept attribute to concepts
or pixels would be useful we also did
some work but we realize that
computation complexity is pretty high
with causal misses
you have other ideas I'd love to hear so
lastly what true things should we be
careful in our journey I think it's
incredibly important to do proper
evaluation we should check even for the
simplest case that we are doing the
right thing if it doesn't do the right
thing in the simplest case we are wrong
we should go back to the drawing board
an including sanity check or some other
ground truth based valuation we should
be doing this so that we can focus our
effort to go somewhere together test
with the humans
the final consumer of your method the
only reason your method exists is for
humans so if you don't check with humans
that's as if you designed a beautiful
train of beautiful classifier and you
never checked on test accuracy have to
check with your campus
remember we're biased and irrational
great book that I love is a cold undoing
project probably a lot of people in the
audience read it by Daniel Kahneman
really loved that book it goes into how
what kind of different biases that we
have and how that's so profound in our
ability to reason we're totally biased
very uh national and we need to take
that into account when we're designing
this talk to your HCI experts the
fastest way to fail interpretability
method it is to have a bad interface or
bad workflow it will not work I
guarantee so work with HCI experts to
get there he'll give me their expertise
to get that part working I'd love to
hear your criticisms of course it's
better if it's a constructive and here
about where we can go from here what do
you not like about this direction that I
suggested what can we do better in Tikal
trilogy let's keep make sure that we're
going to the right direction let's keep
in mind that the goal is to give a tool
for me anyway that is useful for people
so that they can be responsive in the
way that they want
one of the questions why question
wonderful talk um have you thought about
combining and domain expertise with
example the doctor is are using
essentially you can incorporate this
into the loss function and then
gradually phase it out to give the model
if your water start yeah a really good
question the first thing by doctor if TR
said was like oh now it's speaking my
language I can talk to it right can I
tell it that it's doing the wrong thing
we would love to we have some initial
work but I think a lot more work
yes I'm inaudible actually using the
interpreter itself as a means to train
better model somehow incorporated into
the objective yeah really good we are
doing a little bit like birds on the
bell like a type of adversarial training
for example if you're not if you don't
want a layer to be Sasa typical concept
like race then you can make sure that
it's not since the gradient is small so
we were doing like simple fun with that
but I think there's a lot more work
[Applause]